What will tomorrow look like?
Our world is at its limits.
And yet we all want more.
And why not?
Why shouldn't the future be brighter than today?
But where will it come from?
Simple.
Our tiny planet sits in a vast sea of resources, including millions of asteroids...
...bathed in the sun's free energy 24 hours a day.
The same rocks that could fall from our skies...
...also contain everything we could ever need.
Both out there and down here.
It's time someone seized the opportunity.
Deep Space Industries.
Deep Space is a new kind of company with a new kind of plan.
We don't build rockets.
We don't do astronomy.
We are explorers and harvesters, makers and suppliers.
As they say, "timing is everything".
And for space, right now is that time.
In fact, some of the planet's most successful people...
...are placing their bets on this new frontier.
Meanwhile, NASA and others are planning new missions to the Moon and Mars...
...and new space facilities in free space,...
...joining the billions of dollars worth of communication satellites already in orbit.
And as they reach beyond Earth orbit, Deep Space Industries will be there...
...with the fuel, air and materials they need to succeed and grow.